bueno pues en este vídeo vamos a
resolver la ecuación diferencial
logística justo esta que tenemos aquí
ahora bien si recuerdas ya habíamos
encontrado algunas soluciones constantes
en los vídeos pasados y bueno esto
solamente es un pequeño repaso de lo que
vimos hace algunos vídeos si yo aquí
tengo a mis dos ejes este va a ser uno
de ellos este va a ser otro de ellos y
bueno voy a decir que este es el eje del
tiempo o ok esta es mi eje del tiempo
mientras que éste es mi eje de la
población ok
nosotros habíamos encontrado que cuando
tenemos la solución en el dtm igual a
cero y déjeme cambiar de color y voy a
poner este color cuando tenemos n igual
a cero bueno pues date cuenta que esta
parte se anula y entonces todo esto se
hace cero dicho de otra manera entonces
nuestra tasa de cambio va a ser cero
porque todo esto se va a anular es decir
cuando nuestra población es cero pues no
tenemos a nadie que se reproduzca y esta
ecuación diferencial va a ser
consistente con ello solamente nos vamos
a meter
en el valor de 0 y está de lujo que
nuestra tasa de cambio sea 0 se mantiene
constante en 0 todo el tiempo y bueno
estamos hablando que aquí n dt n dtm es
exactamente igual a 0 lo cual es una
solución constante aquí tenemos que la
población nunca cambia ni crece ni nada
interesante ahora
por otra parte habíamos hablado de otra
población constante la cual en la
solución de esta ecuación diferencial
que pasamos si nosotros hacemos en el dt
igual a camps bueno siguiente de t es
igual al valor máximo que puede alcanzar
la población que es que entonces date
cuenta que pasa lo siguiente acá entre
acá es 11 menos 10 y entonces toda esta
ecuación diferencial se va a reducir a 0
o dicho de otra manera la tasa de cambio
de nuevo es 0 que eso quiere decir que
cuando nosotros llegamos al valor de la
población máxima que es camps este valor
de aquí entonces tenemos otra solución
constante porque en este caso nuestra
población tampoco
también se mantiene siendo la misma y
esto es porque nuestra tasa de cambio se
mantiene en 0 así que aquí tenemos otra
solución constante en el dtm n de igual
a igual acá está de aquí donde empezamos
con nuestra población máxima y bueno ahí
nos mantenemos ahora bien seguramente
algo muy interesante va a pasar si nos
tomamos una condición esencial por aquí
la cual voy a llamar n subíndice cero es
decir n de cero cuando el tiempo te vale
cero y bueno vamos a tomarnos esta
condición inicial más cerca del cero que
de esta población máxima que podemos
alcanzar porque si tomamos esta en el
subíndice cero muy pero muy cerca de
cero
entonces date cuenta que esto va a ser
muy pequeño y entonces todo esto va a
ser cercano a 1
y todo esto quiere decir que la tasa de
cambio es muy cercana a un valor
proporcional de n y entonces esto se va
a ver más o menos así cuando nosotros
vamos creciendo nuestro valor de n
nuestra tasa de cambio
a ir creciendo y ahora entre más las
vayamos acercando a este valor de acá
bueno pues date cuenta que esto valdría
uno cercano a uno y esto entonces
valdría cercano a cero eso quiere decir
que nuestra tasa de cambio se va a ir
acercando a cero y entonces esto se va a
ver como una asín total como una a sin
dota al valor de acá y bueno si unimos
esta curva entonces se va a ver más o
menos así la curva que nosotros buscamos
es decir vamos a ver si podemos
encontrar una función en el dtm una
función en eem que nos dé una
representación una gráfica más o menos
parecida a ésta una función nd que sea
solución a esta ecuación diferencial y
fíjate qué interesante estamos buscando
una forma de modelar población o dicho
de otra manera estamos buscando una
solución que sea consistente a la idea
principal de maltos así que vamos a ver
si podemos hacerlo y para eso lo primero
que quiero que te des cuenta es que esta
ecuación diferencial que tengo aquí es
una ecuación diferencial
de separarles es decir que nosotros lo
que buscamos es una n una n que depende
del tiempo una n dt que sea solución de
esta ecuación diferencial y bueno como
no tenemos el tiempo de una manera
explícita
entonces se me ocurre que la forma más
sencilla de resolver esto es decidir
todo entre esta parte que tenemos aquí
entre todo esto que tenemos aquí voy a
dejar de este lado al aire porque bueno
creo que así va a ser la forma más
sencilla de resolverlo y voy a dividir
todo entre esta parte que tengo aquí y
que va a quedar
bueno pues me va a quedar entonces que
uno entre entre bueno pues toda esta
parte de aquí así que déjenme ponerla
uno entre nm que multiplica a su vez a
uno menos entre khan ok vamos a ponerlo
esto que multiplica su vez a uno ok
- nm am vamos a ponerlo con este color
menos nm dividida entre acá ok esto es
dividido entre acá esto que a su vez
multiplica bueno a esta parte de aquí y
es más déjeme atraparla ok y la voy a
copiar y la voy
ok esto que multiplica a esta parte que
tenemos aquí ok vamos a ponerlo así y
voy a poner que estos dos están
multiplicando am ok esto va a ser
exactamente igual que y de este lado
bueno pues solamente me quedo con er y
bueno hay varias formas de resolver esto
que tengo aquí pero se me ocurre que lo
podemos hacer
sumándonos la anti derivada con respecto
al tiempo y bueno de esta parte va a ser
muy sencillo me quedaría rt más una
constante pero esta parte parece ser un
poco enredada así que para tomarme el
anti derivada con respecto al tiempo de
esta parte se me ocurre que lo puedo
resolver por fracciones parciales así
que vamos a buscar una y una vez y
déjame ponerlo aquí voy a buscar una am
que al dividirla entre n ok
más voy a buscar otra vez otra vez que
al dividirla entre bueno entre esta
parte que tengo aquí que es
1 - n / camps ok esto sea exactamente
igual que bueno pues esta expresión que
tengo aquí esto sea exactamente igual
que uno entre am n que multiplica a 1 -
n entre cam y bueno esto es el método de
la expansión en fracciones parciales te
encargo que si no recuerdas bien cómo
resolver este tipo de ecuaciones pausa
el vídeo justo ahora y vayas a la
sección de khan academy que habla de la
expansión en fracciones parciales ok y
entonces vamos a trabajarlo aquí que nos
va a quedar si yo hago la suma de estos
dos bueno pues esto me va a quedar a que
multiplicar a este de aquí y eso es lo
mismo que a al menos a entre camps y
entre camps esto que a su vez multiplica
n y bueno a esto le voy a sumar ok
esta vez que multiplica está n esta b
por n y todo esto está dividido
todo esto está dividido entre
la multiplicación de estos dos entre n
que multiplica a 1 - n entre k ok y esto
voy a hacer de paréntesis otra forma de
verlo es que estoy multiplicando esta
fracción que tengo aquí por 1 - en entre
cada tanto arriba como abajo a por 1 -
entre acá bueno pues es esta parte de
aquí a menos
entre cada por n y la parte de abajo me
va a quedar la multiplicación de estos
dos y ahora a este de aquí lo voy a
multiplicar tanto arriba como abajo por
n y me va a quedar
bn y estos dos se van a pasar
multiplicando y ahora cuando lo sumo me
queda esta expresión que tengo aquí y
esto tiene que ser exactamente igual que
uno entre ok n que multiplican a 1 - n
entre acá y fíjate que lo que estoy
logrando al hacer esto es que ahora
tengamos el mismo denominador en estas
dos fracciones y ya con esto entonces
vamos a decir que todo lo que tenga que
ser constante aquí va a ser igual a 1
y todo lo que tenga que ver con n lo
podemos brasil esto va a ser igual a 0
porque aquí tengo 10 n dicho otra manera
y déjame tomar este color esta parte de
aquí esta parte de aquí ok
más ven o sea esta parte de aquí esto
tiene que ser igual a 0 que son los
coeficientes que tenemos al lado de la n
mientras que por otra parte esta parte
que tengo aquí
tiene que ser igual al coeficiente
constante que tengo aquí que es 1 dicho
otra manera
am aquí me va a quedar que am debe de
ser igual que 1 ok
déjame bajar ahora un poco la pantalla y
por otra parte me va a quedar que menos
a entre cam eso lo voy a poner como
menos 1 entre acá porque ya sabemos el
valor de amd menos 1 entre acá
ok más ven más
esto tiene que ser igual a cero esto
tiene que ser igual a cero o dicho de
otra manera ve que es justo lo que
queríamos va a tomar el valor de 1 entre
camps y así ya estoy obteniendo el valor
de amd y el valor de ver y esto nos va a
ayudar a que esto lo podemos escribir de
la siguiente manera utilizando la
expansión en fracciones parciales y que
nos va a quedar bueno pues aquí tengo am
a / n lo cual es lo mismo que 1-1 amplio
voy a poner justo aquí 1 entre n en esta
de este color ok ya esto
le voy a sumar ok am bem entre 1 - entre
k&b vale 1 entre camps así que lo voy a
poner justo con este color me queda 1
entre cam ok esto que a su vez está
dividido entre esta expresión que tengo
aquí que es 1 ok
- n entre k - ok n entre acá y acá está
de este color
todo esto todo esto a su vez están
multiplicando a bueno a esta expresión
que tengo aquí es más déjame ponerlo
justo así voy a tratar esto ok y lo voy
a copiar y lo voy a pegar ok y ahora
esto lo voy a poner justo aquí y vamos a
poner que esto se está multiplicando ok
ahora a esta parte de aquí por ahora
creo que ya no nos va a servir mucho más
esto nos ayudó a entender la expansión
en fracciones parciales lo cual nos va a
ayudar mucho con nuestra anti derivada
pero lo voy a quitar justo de aquí para
que no nos estorbe más en nuestro
desarrollo si tú necesitas ver de nuevo
el vídeo o al menos esa parte del vídeo
para entender bien cómo llegué a esta
expresión de aquí lo puedes volver a
hacer pero por ahora necesito un poco de
espacio muy bien ahora tengo esta
expresión aquí y creo que esto me va a
ayudar mucho más en contra del anti
derivado al menos lo primero que puedes
ver es que la anti derivada de 1 entre n
parece ser ya más fácil de encontrar y
bueno es tanto derivada ahorita
trabajamos ok porque si nosotros
pensamos en la anti derivada de 1 / n
bueno pues eso sabemos que es el
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
n déjame ponerlo así déjenme cambiar de
color y aquí voy a poner am la derivada
ok con respecto a en el primero con
respecto a n de el logaritmo natural del
valor absoluto de n bueno nosotros
sabemos que esto es lo mismo que la
derivada de n con respecto a n lo cual
es uno entre esto que tengo aquí que es
n y ahora sí me quiero tomar la derivada
con respecto al tiempo con respecto al
tiempo de el logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de n bueno pues esto es lo
mismo que la derivada con respecto a n
de esto que es uno entre n ok por la
derivada con respecto al tiempo de n la
derivada de n con respecto al tiempo
esto por la regla de la cadena justo es
esta parte de aquí ahora si nos fijamos
en esta expresión que tengo aquí en esto
que tengo aquí
bueno pues date cuenta que también casi
tenemos su derivada
y si nosotros calculamos la derivada de
esto que tengo aquí me va a quedar
solamente menos 1 entre acá y acá arriba
tengo uno entre cada positivo así que es
casi su derivada es más para hacerlas su
derivada lo que podemos hacer es dejar
meditar este signo más aquí y voy a
poner en lugar de un signo más voy a
poner un menos menos es decir esto me va
a quedar como un menos aquí y acá arriba
voy a poner un menos menos por menos me
da más el más que teníamos antes pero
ahora acá arriba tengo la derivada de
esta expresión que tengo acá abajo y eso
me va a ayudar mucho a encontrar su anti
derivada y es más para que todo quede
muy claro déjenme escribir de aquí si yo
me quiero tomar la derivada con respecto
a n ok de el logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de esto que tengo acá abajo de
uno menos n entre camps
bueno pues cursando la regla de la
cadena nos va a quedar la derivada de
esto lo cual es a menos 1 entre khan
/ cam ok que a su vez multiplica a la
derivada del logaritmo natural de todo
esto y bueno esto es exactamente lo
mismo que a 1 entre esto mismo de aquí
1 - n entre cam n entre camps entre
camps ok de lujo y si nosotros queremos
calcular la derivada con respecto al
tiempo de el logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de esto que tenemos aquí
1 - n entre camps ok si utilizamos la
regla de la cadena esto nos va a quedar
justo esta parte que tengo aquí y es más
déjeme atraparla con esto ok la voy a
atrapar ok vamos a copiarlo y pegarlo y
a esto hay que multiplicarlo justo a
esto hay que multiplicarlo por bueno
pues por la derivada de n con respecto
al tiempo y porque estoy haciendo esto
bueno porque date cuenta que esto de
aquí es exactamente lo mismo que tenemos
aquí y date cuenta que éste
sobre de tema está multiplicando a estos
dos es decir que si nosotros
distribuimos esta parte que tengo aquí
me va a quedar justo expresiones como
éstas deja de hacerlo de la siguiente
manera
si yo copio esta parte de aquí la voy a
atrapar con esto ok vamos a copiar y
pegar ok a me va a quedar 1 / n ok esto
que a su vez multiplica a esta parte de
aquí déjame a distribuir vamos a
distribuir este paréntesis ok ya esto
hay que quitarle porque aquí tengo un
signo menos a esto le voy a quitar bueno
pues esta parte de aquí que también voy
a hacer lo mismo voy a atraparlo ok lo
voy a copiar y lo voy a pegar o que ya
lo tengo aquí lo voy a poner justo por
acá que a su vez multiplica a tn con
respecto al tiempo ok
aún me queda esta parte de aquí y ahora
lo voy a poner justo por acá estos dos
están multiplicando y bueno ahora desde
cuenta que esto va a ser igual que
y ahora esto nos va a ayudar bastante a
poder encontrar nuestras antes derivadas
que tanto queríamos y ahora sí si
nosotros tomamos la anti derivada con
respecto al tiempo de esta parte que
tengo aquí bueno pues que me va a quedar
date cuenta que esto fuente derivada es
justo lo que tenemos aquí y entonces me
va a quedar am el logaritmo natural y
déjame ponerlo así el logaritmo natural
ok del valor absoluto de n ok esto
- aquí tengo un menos y bueno si me tomo
la anti derivada de esta parte que tengo
aquí es decir de todo esto que tengo
aquí con respecto al tiempo
bueno pues date cuenta que vamos a
llegar justo a esta expresión que
tenemos aquí es decir al logaritmo
natural del valor absoluto de 1 - n
entre k ok ya esto ok en valor absoluto
esto va a ser exactamente igual ao
espera no olvidemos las constantes esto
al sacar su anti derivada ok obtenemos 1
le voy a poner una constante 1 y esto va
a ser exactamente igual a la anti
derivada con respecto al tiempo de esta
parte lo cual es r ok déjame ponerlo con
este color es er que multiplica bueno al
tiempo r que multiplica el tiempo y a
esto hay que sumarle bueno pues otra
constante de integración que sale de
sacar la anti derivada de este otro lado
más otra constante 2 ok y si ahora yo
bajó un poco la pantalla vamos a bajar
un poco la pantalla entonces qué voy a
obtener y es que si ahora suponemos am y
dejamos subir un poco la pantalla si
suponemos que nuestra n dt m está justo
en este intervalo es decir que nunca es
más pequeña o igual que 0 y nunca es más
grande o igual que acá o vamos a ponerlo
justo aquí si suponemos su
mus ok que n de nd y esto siempre es más
grande que 0 ok
justo como en este ejemplo y es menor
que acá entonces date cuenta de lo
siguiente en esta expresión que tengo
aquí nos va a ayudar a simplificar
bastante las cosas han dejado subir
ahora un poco la pantalla porque
entonces ahora date cuenta que yo puedo
eliminar estos valores absolutos si yo
veo que n siempre es más grande que ser
on bueno entonces esto de aquí siempre
va a ser positivo así que no es
necesario ponerlo vamos a quitar este
valor fruta de aquí y si yo supongo que
n siempre es menor que acá entonces esta
expresión que tengo aquí completa va a
ser siempre mayor que 0 por lo tanto no
es necesario poner este otro valor
absoluto también lo voy a quitar de aquí
y ahora sí suponiendo que n dt está
entre 0 y cam bueno pues ya puedo
obtener esta parte de aquí lo cual me
ayuda un poco a simplificar las cosas
déjame poner aquí un paréntesis y bueno
ok por aquí también necesitó unos
paréntesis y si ahora lo que voy a hacer
es restar a uno de ambos lados de esta
ecuación o cuando de hecho déjame hacer
esto en el siguiente vídeo porque este
vídeo está quedando enorme y es que
estoy tan emocionado porque estoy muy
pero muy cerca de llegar a la solución
que yo quería pero no te apures en el
siguiente vídeo voy a seguir resolviendo
y encontrando la solución que estamos
buscando que cerca estamos